et un nouveau jugement contre les époux
balkany aujourd'hui patrick balkany
l'ancien maire de levallois a été
condamné à cinq ans de prison ferme pour
blanchiment aggravé et sa femme à quatre
ans de prison sa femme qui est maire par
intérim de levallois alors blanchiment
aggravé parce qu'en fait les balkany ont
été convaincus d'avoir dissimulé au fisc
beaucoup d'argent qu'ils ont utilisés
notamment pour se construire des villas
dans des pays plus ensoleillé que
levallois perret et c'est la deuxième
condamnation un des balkany puisqu'il y
en avait déjà une en septembre que le
mois dernier cette fois pour fraude
fiscale et la patrick balkany avait été
condamné à 13 ans de prison alors
première réaction pardon cinq ans ferme
pourquoi est ce que je dis 13 ans dix
ans d'inéligibilité
mais pour la promotion précédente pour
celle de septembre
et ben non alors c'est moi qui vais
aller trop vite merci de m'avoir
corriger on va écouter cette réaction
d'isabelle balkany à la sortie du
tribunal pourrait ce qui était important
c'est que certes cette fois ils sont
condamnés pour blanchiment mais c'est
blanchiment d'argent qui leur
appartenait il n'y a pas eu détournement
d'argent public simplement vous dit
comme nous l'avons toujours dit et comme
cela a été confirmé publiquement et
officiellement aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
un centime d'argent public
c'est uniquement notre patrimoine
familial et il n'y a pas de corruption
merci quand même c'est pas facile de
commenter une décision de justice à
chaud comme ça mais ça paraît à peu près
équilibré où est ce que comme pour la
précédente condamnation on peut penser
que la justice a eu la main lourde pour
faire un exemple
alors la justice a pas eu la main lourde
parce que les réquisitions du parquet a
été plus sévère c'était sept ans de
prison donc là ils ont 10 ans
d'inégibilité aussi mais au fond on si
on prend le procès juppé de 2004 en
première instance il avait écopé d'une
peine qui avait été déjà aussi très fins
lourdes proportionnellement cédé 18 mois
avec sursis et 10 ans d'inégibilité
et on appelle décembre 2004 la peine
d'inéligibilité avaient été réduites à
un an et les 18 mois et est passé à 14
mois avec sursis donc au fond ce qu'il
ya surtout on a tendance un peu à
l'oublier c'est que c'est la stratégie
de défense utilisée par les balkany en
première instance qui était complètement
si vous me permettez l'expression
complètement foireuse le pauvre dupond
moretti a essayé d'appliquer une
stratégie et balkany s'est employé à la
détruire
je vous coupe 20 secondes on va
l'entendre à la stratégie d'eric
dupond-moretti on requiert aujourd'hui
contre cet homme qui est peut-être
aujourd'hui le l'incarnation du mal
absolu dans cette france qui devient
puritaine en requiert aujourd'hui contre
lui ce que parfois on ne retire pas dans
les crimes de sang voilà c'est tout ce
que je voudrais vous dire car il y avait
aussi un autre exemple c'est qu'à un
moment ils ont essayé de 10 de dire que
patrick balkany était très affecté très
affaiblie par la tentative de suicide de
son épouse et que cet homme de 71 ans
est là patrick balkany a interrompu son
avocat en dire non
j'ai 70 ans ne vieillissez pas genre la
boutade
on va bien rigoler et donc ça détruisait
complètement l'image qui essayait de
faire passer dupond moretti et après
pendant tout le procès au delà de cette
boutade il y avait aussi
une sorte d'arrogance une sorte de
supériorité et ça ça déplaît au juge
c'est évident donc de toutes façons on
imagine très bien qu'ils vont faire
appel pour au moins échappé à
l'inéligibilité de première instance et
éventuellement pouvoir se présenter aux
élections municipales
il faudra voir vraiment au moment de
l'appel quand tu auras la peine
prononcée
voilà et comme si tout à l'heure je la
corrigerai nouveau il ya donc eu pour la
précédente condamnation quatre ans de
prison et dix ans d'inéligibilité
contrairement à ce que j'avais indiqués
alors je sais pas si vous avez le temps
de lire le figaro de ce matin j'en doute
pas il y avait un papier intéressant il
y en a beaucoup qui raconte comment les
balkany sont toujours aussi populaires à
levallois malgré ces condamnations à
répétition même si l'article avait été
fait avant le dernier jugement
paolo levi comment est ce que vous vous
expliquer qu'on puisse avoir eu des
problèmes avec la justice s'y être
populaire est ce que ça ne vous rappelle
pas un peu quelques responsables de
premier plan italien qui ont pu être
premier ministre par exemple
complètement complètement je pense que
là vous fait un petit clin d'oeil à un
autre avec l'ancien président du conseil
c'est lui voilà le boss la momie
voilà et c'est exactement le même un
mécanisme lui il l'a fait disons à
l'échelle nationale les balkany à
l'échelle de levallois perret mais c'est
vrai que il y à une partie de la
population qui paradoxalement renforce
même le soutien
à ces représentants là quand ils sont
persécutés entre guillemets parce qu'ils
pensent justement qui sont persécutés
par par la justice la stratégie de
défense de berlusconi a été toujours
celle d'attaquer de façon très virulente
la magistrature de gauche qui lui en
voulait et il y avait toute une partie 2
de la population qui croyait à cette
thèse est et c'est un petit peu la même
chose avec les balkany après on peut
tracer aussi un parallèle parce que et
les balkany et berlusconi c'est un petit
peu d des représentants d'un vieux monde
qui quelque part avait aussi un certain
charme c'est à dire que c'est des
personnes très attachante et très
sympathique il arrive et on disait une
chose sur berlusconi pour pour le
détester il faut ne jamais l'avoir
connue pour dorel ne jamais l'avoir
croisé dans la rue moi même qui
fustigeait berlusconi en le regardant la
télé ensuite je l' ai connu à bruxelles
quand on était au concert robin et
c'était un homme qui vraiment avait
cette capacité avec n'importe qui
d'arriver à tisser un lien une empathie
très très forte je pense que les balkany
à leur échelle à levallois perret ils
ont ils ont fait un petit peu la même
chose et je pense qu'aujourd'hui encore
quand on se promène dans les rues de
levallois et on a pu voir quand quand
isabelle balkany est descendu dans dans
la place du marché le jour de
l'incarcération de son mari ou le jour
d'après le jour suivant il y avait toute
la ville qui était à ses côtés et donc
c'est étonnant mais mais le parallèle
est tout à fait pertinente berlusconi et
balkany c'était bien aussi avec l'argent
la manne de la défense
la manne de l'agent fluide dont ils
bénéficient aussi il nous fait bien
nos internautes considèrent que oui les
balkany sont des justiciables comme les
autres à soixante dix huit pour cent
qu'est ce que vous entendez par là
écoutez cette réaction de granger la
réponse est dans la question
du moins si l'on se base sur la loi si
la justice doit se baser sur l'opinion
personnelle on peut très bien aussi se
rendre à l'anarchie ou et ça c'est sans
doute s'il ya une subjectivité trop
grande pour les magistrats et cette
réaction de patrick les balkany
populaire pour l'interrogation avec une
ville en surendettement pour
l'interrogation c'est vrai adrien matou
que levallois est une ville extrêmement
endettée mais encore une fois
apparemment rien ne pouvait entacher la
popularité de patrick balkany
ça ça vous surprend comme journaliste
politique alors à première vue ça peut
surprendre parce que je pense
qu'effectivement dans un l'échelle
nationale je suis pas sûr qu'il soit
extrêmement populaire à l'échelle de la
ville alors déjà il ya ce côté je la
tenais grand claques dans le dos à tout
le monde je suis très sympa qui peut
jouer et mais finalement l'endettement
de levallois peut avoir un rapport
finalement avec la popularité
ça veut dire que la ville investit
beaucoup d'argent fait beaucoup de
projets de beaucoup les gens et que les
gens forcément ils pensent pas toujours
à long terme et il voit ce qui se passe
dans leur ville ils ont peut-être
l'impression qu'elle est bien gérée un
bon verre car c'est quelqu'un qui ouvre
des crèches qui distribue des cadeaux
pour noël et c'était le cas des de
patrick balkany
c'est ce qu'on appelle du clientélisme
ce que fait l'ancien monde mais il faut
se rappeler qu'en 1983 quand il gagne la
ville
c'est une ville pauvre de la banlieue
parisienne qui fait détenu par les
partis communistes ils gagnent 50,3
enfin c'est très peu et d'ailleurs il ya
un recours fin il ya des tricheries pssa
aujourd'hui quand vous faites une
élection municipale à bâle à levallois
il ya deux listes de droite au second
tour pour vous ou non mais il faut
imaginer comment cette ville a été
totalement transformé
c'était des ateliers il y avait des
usines de voitures tout ça a été rasé
aujourd'hui c'est c'est presque le 21ème
arrondissement de paris le métro va
directement là donc il ya toute une
population de classe moyenne plutôt
aisée dans certains endroits notamment
proche de denis qui a complètement
changé la physionomie de la ville et qui
est satisfaite de ce que fait de ce que
font les balkany parce que
ça leur profite ce commentaire de
macabres nito c'est la base du
clientélisme s'endetter pour acheter des
voix alors acheté par des priori à l'apa
directeur pour acheter par des
équipements sportifs et des aides de
toutes sortes
caroline valentin est ce que tout ça est
très moral est-ce que balkany est très
moral mais est-ce que d'abord c'est un
endroit qui reste populaire
non mais on ne prête qu'aux riches donc
l'endettement d'une commune comme
levallois qui bénéficie une fois de plus
avec 4 avec trois autres communes de la
manne de la défense c'est pas grave
la mission des impôts locaux l'ex taxe
professionnelle payée par les
entreprises en plus donc maintenant la
question initiale c'était est-ce que
balkany est un justiciable comme les
autres
et ça c'est une question qui reste
intéressante alors je vous la poser à
vos lecteurs je crois qu'en démocratie
quand on a un certain respect pour la
justice
on ne peut pas tellement se prononcer
sur la légitimité d'une peine sans avoir
lu le dossier est aujourd'hui ici
personne d'entre nous n'a lu ce dossier
donc personne n'est capable de dévaluer
a priori savoir si quatre cinq ans de
prison c'est bien c'est pas bien notre
défense
le verdict est tombé ya peu de temps
donc c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas eu le
temps de se pencher dessus avec même si
vous aviez une deux semaines de plus
vous auriez pas été dans le dossier que
vous avez pas ce que vous pouvez faire
c'est simplement commenté
les arguments et les débats qui auront
des gens qui ont connu le dossier je
crois que c'est assez important de le
dire maintenant ce que dit dupont
moretti c'est assez intéressant
il parle il dit en briques en requiert
dans ce dossier là moi que je compris
pour les crimes de sang et ça c'est
intéressant en fait parce
qu'effectivement on n'est pas que ce
qu'il est en train de dire c'est que la
justice vis-à-vis balkany et est
beaucoup plus faire beaucoup plus dur
que la justice vis-à-vis des crimes de
sang des atteintes aux personnes et
c'est vrai que là il ya une plainte
généralisée dans les effectifs de la
police tout avant
concernant les atteintes aux personnes
les agressions des personnes passent
leur temps à dire on trouve la personne
qui a agressé la ville d'agde et dames
mais elle ressort du tribunal aussi sec
on trouve la personne qui a violé la
jeune fille mais elle ressort du de
prison assez vite et ça c'est une vraie
interrogation que l'on peut avoir en
démocratie c'est de demander peut-être à
un organisme comme la crau décompresser
pas celle là mais peut-être le nm je
sais pas de faire une vraie évaluation
des peines selon les différents domaines
moi un viol me choque énormément et
aujourd'hui il n'est pas bien sanctionné
puisqu'il peut y avoir une forme de
justice entre guillemets politique on
s'accepte volontiers un homme de droite
qui s'est enrichie et lui qu' un petit
voyou à qui on trouve les excès alors
ensuite après on pourrait faire
effectivement savoir l étude des
sanctions judiciaires qui ont touché les
hommes de droit tous les hommes de
gauche
ce qui est clair c'est que dans la
sphère balkany ça a mal commencé puisque
la décision de
c'était quand la fois dernière c'était
en septembre s'est accompagnée d'un
mandat de dépôt mandat de dépôt qui
juridiquement n'était absolument pas
justifiée donc c'est on abaisse de dire
que partout les bâtonniers parti en
prison direct médiatement on peut dire
que patrick balkany était considéré
comme étant un danger pour la société et
qu'il fallait donc l'enfermer pour qu'il
ne lui apporte pas atteinte
on voit pas comme un justiciable comme
en a mis en examen dans un dossier de
fraude fiscale peut constituer un danger
pour les gens autour de lui même si la
hausse est ce qu'on imagine patrick
balkany fuir levallois la france voir
l'europe pour échapper à la justice a
semblé quand même grotesque d'ailleurs
c'est ce que son avocat a condamné
fermement et sa demande de mise en
liberté sera examinée 22 octobre ce qui
est intéressant de dire c'est que cette
fois ci sa condamnation n'a pas été
accompagnée d'un mandat de dépôt
elle aurait pu l'être en dépit du fait
que patrick balkany était en prison et
ça aurait rendu la demande de mise en
liberté
l'examen des demandes de mise en liberté
plus périlleuses ça aurait forcé ses
avocats demandaient une autre
demande de mise en liberté puis un
deuxième point c'est qu'ils peuvent
demander aussi la confusion des peines
c'est à dire qu'au lieu de considérer
qu'il a eu 57 5 ans cette fois-ci et 80
fois dernière donc de vente où ils
peuvent demander de faire en sorte qu'il
n'est que cinq ans c'est à dire la peine
même la peine la plus importante ça
aussi on va peut-être voir
voilà c'est peut-être à répondre à la
question est ce que des balkany est un
justiciable comme les autres
et puis pour relativiser ce que j'ai dis
quand même entre les hommes du blick de
gauche et de droite il faut quand même
rappeler que jérôme cahuzac ancien
ministre socialiste du budget avait été
lui aussi lourdement condamnés pour
voilà pour évasion fiscale
d'abord je voulais une très longtemps et
dont la dépouille n'a pas fait de prison
il n'a pas fait de prison et il n'a
jamais mis un pied en prison il a un
bracelet électronique alors on saura si
pour cinq ans de prison versus 4 balkany
va en prison ou s'il un bracelet
électronique
mais encore une fois je reviens aussi là
dessus sur la stratégie de défense
utilisée c'est ça ça joue énormément les
juges mais oui car les choses
et oui et il ya un moment c'est
peut-être pas bien la réaction des juges
mais où d'abord qu'elle a voulu se le
payer parce que c'est on ne peut pas
justifier la base la partialité des
juges
ils n'ont pas à réagir en fait que un
bidule et discourtois que truc est un
peu nerveux
voilà elle lui doit ça va au delà ça
c'est à dire qu'il ya aussi le une
manière de regarder sa faute présumée
c'est ça va au delà de l'attitude dans
le cas de balkany on a l'impression que
qu'il est prêt à recommencer dès qu'ils
auront l'occasion quand il regarde choix
des races voilà mon mea culpa ou trois
morts emma 77 à cette remarque un peu
perfide peut-être la semaine prochaine
pour on nous parlait de richard ferrand
d'alexandre benalla et de tous les gens
de là ma chronique qui échappe à la
justice
alors quand même battu 77 il faut dire
que c'est pas fini enrichiront il a été
mis en examen mais il n'a pas encore été
acquitté donc pour l'instant il est
entre les mains de la justice et puis
cette question peut-être en forme de
conclusion le client cette question du
paiement sont le clientélisme des mers
n'est-il pas à la base même du rejet de
la politique en france pas écouté voilà
c'est un sujet de réflexion pour le week
end
on avait parlé d' eric dupond moretti
l'avocat des balkany est bien le revoilà
mais dans un an
sujet qui n'a rien à voir il y à ce
matin une tribune qui est signée dans le
figaro par une quarantaine de
personnalités dont eric dupond-moretti
dont l'ancien ministre françoise nyssen
mais il est vrai qu'elle est une femme
du sud
des comédiens très connus comme pierre
arditi ou jean reno et de quoi est-ce
qu'ils n'ont pas